[Music]
it's our National Anthem that's a pretty
good one man that's uh it's pretty good
oh I can see you
my scanners I'm not detecting any what
did I take detect audio Oh agent burns
Jhansi so agent burns yes you are the
first one we met my son called b-57b 127
or you call him bumblebee right that's
that's a nickname that people call him
I'm not sure if I acknowledge that his
agent burns I know it must be 127 my
scanners are detecting your name is
Travis Knight yes that is correct
I am BB Cinquecento I am the father of
how you call him bumblebee pear my
scanners saying that you are a director
so you have a stretch power for a human
you can decide what happen next right
yeah I don't know about that your
directors do not have godlike power
despite what some people think and
despite with actually with some
directors think but you know it you do
have some some ability to shake things
yes I think there is some truth to that
and you are the only friend of my son
bumblebee yes what is it friend well a
friend is someone that you can count on
and rely on talk to laugh with hang out
with is it like a father
mmm similar similar so why would you not
call him bumblebee because that would
give
more of a humanization to what I believe
is a machine you'll have to watch the
movie and figure that out for an answer
[Music]
so why do people like robots or why do
you don't like bras
I feel robots are out to destroy us I
think other people in the movies
specifically have more of a human
connection and that's why they enjoy and
maybe come up with nicknames like
bumblebee I could come up with a
nickname for you right now but I mean
that would take away your identity when
I see when I look at you as a big number
too so for me you would be like a big
number too but I don't do that to you
because that may change your identity
and change the way people perceive you
they look at you and I count guys
nothing but a big number too you are
very nice human but other humans are
very mean to me oh why is that I don't
know oh I'm so sorry to hear that I
think a lot of people are scared of
anything that's not like them
so it's you know whether it be you know
people that look different or
experiences that are different or a big
sentient space-age robot people are
afraid of those things that they don't
know where they don't understand but
there is one girl she is called Charlie
Watson
she helps bumblebee right she does yes
she I mean Charlie really is bumblebees
best friend in the world and they meet
each other and they grow very close
together and they essentially make this
this beautiful relationship that they
force together they make each other
whole
[Applause]
well here's the deal people can be
terrible about things they don't
understand I want to be nice to people
so can you give me a nickname well I
would I would say big number to make
number two yeah you're number two so I
don't know your first time does it pick
number one burns well I mean if it's a
big number one I got to start drinking
more water I can do that I can do that
yeah I'll take that
why do people need water it's 70% of
their makeup it's the lifeblood of
existence it's the most precious
commodity cuz I don't know yeah so I
know it's not like you need hydraulic
fluid or oil or whatever it is that we
need that grinds your gears over there
do you have it on earth I think you
could find it and maybe a local hardware
Depot maybe not a price or maybe online
I didn't give bumblebee such a nice name
like you how would you give me that
birth name uh its BB 500 yes um I like
that I wouldn't change that I think you
should run with it thank you that is a
great name so how does a normal day look
like with a transformer um
well huh the honest answer um looks like
me talking into into space really
sometimes a tennis ball I'll be you know
making faces at a tennis ball a tennis
ball yes a tennis ball on a stick 13 13
feet high that is new so bumblebee can
now transform also an ax stake and a
tennis ball that's right
there's a war raging on our planet
if this criminal isn't found that war
may find its way sir anyone who can help
you you're the family well we are
friendly like you know my son was very
friendly hmm but he's
there are underwear yes what do you
think about them I really have a good
outlook on all the transforming robots I
think I'm very reserved I always think
you guys are up to something eventually
hopefully you'll prove me wrong
but until then I always think you're are
something what have you done there we've
done something with your eyes
oh yeah it's a nervous twitch I got it
back in 1987 when I ran to a
transforming robot I'm sorry it was it
my son yeah be 127 yeah I'm very sorry
for that thing I had don't worry about
it don't about it be number two so do
you think that humans and transformers
can be friends they most certainly can
be yes you know just like just like
anything just like anybody where there
are people and other creatures that we
get along with and don't but we all have
the ability to make connections yes so
humans have multiple options to choose
yes so you can like robots or a promotes
this certainly yes because we can do
everything better than you humans how
it's had a fact yeah we are normally are
perfect and humans are let's say not
perfect yes that is true
humans are not perfect but I believe
there is beauty in imperfection agent
burns yes what do you think of him he's
not very nice no luckily the person that
plays him John Cena great guy agent
burns questionable not very nice you
know rather gruff he's got a very
powerful presence it's a very large
person scary there's one man who I think
yes perfect agent burns what would you
describe him agent burns burns he's
physically pretty perfect rippling
pectorals and the arms the size of oak
trees yes but he's flawed just like we
all are because he has a point of view
that is
maybe a little too blinker a little too
narrow I was studying humans and I
analyzed there's a word called irony
what does it mean is it from irony
yeah yes it is it is it derives from the
element iron and it's it's a joint
replacement therapy where if a human's
knees is faulty
they replace the knee with an iron neat
irony yes it is very entertaining yes
strike I've seen firsthand these things
really are
bumblebee but I brought you something
again okay is it a December - it's the
national anthem from our Transformers
maybe it's a very easy okay very good
- farmers role of in disguise means
bi-national that's a pretty good one man
that's it it's pretty good how do you
have a message to all transformers go
see this movie on December 20th
it's called bumblebee and it's wonderful
your son did an incredible job
and it's worth saying I'm very proud of
my son
I'm very happy that he has such a great
friend thank you so much
do you have a message to all the
Transformers and to all the humans yes I
do
Cosi bumblebee in theaters this
Christmas it's awesome it's got
something for everybody including
transformers and humans okay I have
another thought I think it's your
National Anthem
mine yeah hmm your time is up my time is
now you can't see me my time is now it's
the franchise boy i'm shining now you
can see me my time is now damn yeah
that's catchy oh yeah I like that tune I
would like to hear that song that's a
good idea
well since you're not from this planet
you know
copyright holds on that I'm just gonna
keep this for me it's it's you're sorry
you couldn't keep it yeah keep this I
think that that's me on skype future I
think I can do some of that thank you
very much but I mean I'm never yeah
exactly
pound it out it's just me touching ducks
at the big number to appreciate it thank
you very much
18 points Thank You number two
we're gonna have triple-a batteries
powered by triple-a batteries when I
came to earth my bed we drain that's
surprising sentient space-age robot has
got a hand cannon powered by triple-a
batteries they have those on Cybertron
do they yeah that's awesome that's
awesome I won't if you can't remember I
was the ball last yeah of course man of
course always good to see you yes always
good to see you as well and always
respect the presentation
[Music]